Lady's Voice: Spreading in new markets around the world
A great way to find new users and increase revenue.
So we're happy to offer ten tips that developers have been able to do
Making use of local success despite their international reach
In search of opportunities for success.
Many of these tips apply to apps as well.
International deployment begins with the design of the game code
It coordinates its screens.
You should allow for diversity in terms of language and composition of sentences and letters
Numbers and figures representation
Because you will be exposed during translation.
For example, leaving a space of 30% of the additional space blank helps in
User interface elements avoid problems in other languages.
Be sure to store all the content you change when you translate
In a file of resource files
So you do not have to re-type the code when translating.
Use the formats available in the system with date, time, and numbers
The currency even corresponds
Your application automatically with what the user chooses.
Not yet available to all users
Data connection is cheap and reliable.
The game that can be played offline will still be verified
A record increase in attracting a new audience.
Make sure the game installation package is as small as possible.
Users sometimes skip installing large games because of
Concerns about device memory or data transfer rate.
Understand the audience's request and preferences.
Look for large cultural differences and use symbols
Levels as well as scenarios in the game that you may raise
Sensitivity of local users.
Look for local interests in game colors,
Simple games with nice icons
Representing importance in Japan and Korea for example, as for games
War strategies are important in Germany and Russia.
Find out how local users pay for
Get games and content within apps.
If your carrier billing is common,
Monthly restrictions may affect the number and intensity
In-app purchases.
There are many common expectations among
Western markets.
Users in these markets are very excited
For game icons based on simple characters without words,
As well as for screen shots that show the actual playing mode,
Also like to start quickly and explore new features gradually,
Games drawn from the reality can be attracted to a lot of frequency on the game,
As they attract prices that do not exceed 99. of the currency
There are also many common expectations
Between the Eastern markets.
For example, in Japan users prefer simplified games
The use of symbols includes glamorous characters
On cartoon style and manga,
However, the most explicit game codes
Must reflect the theme of the game,
They also prefer color screen shots
Which refers to the content and theme of the game world,
They also prefer to interact with simplified games that include a high learning curve,
And expect prices for the application does not exceed zero,
Preferring to pre-register for elements within the game as a reward.
Keep this in mind as a starting point for your search.
You must engage a professional third party
It offers you a translation service as you can use
With your local audience for a high-resolution translation of the app.
You can use the translation service at
Application Developer Console.
You only need to send the original text in resource files.
You will not need to modify your development
So that it fits in with the translator.
You'll also need to add the text of your Play Store listing
Until it is translated as well.
The test is also an essential element
Since small translation errors can be very embarrassing
Regardless of the great effort I have made in preparing the text for translation,
Some text may be left truncated or in a format
Not safe.
Use local users to test.
Continue with User Forum.
Through this forum you can take advantage of language skills
And a great local experience.
The translated app needs to market an interpreter.
Local marketing can include a localized data card,
Or support from members of the local user forum,
Or to publish the application in the local language on global social networks
And local channels as well,
Or a collection of press articles that are sent to important media and blogs
As well as translated advertising campaigns
To launch local installations and enhance local offerings.
Users prefer to have a good idea of ​​how the game is played
Before you install them.
Adding a promotional clip to a Play Store listing can help
In encouraging users to make a decision.
When you create a promotion,
Do not forget to create market-specific versions.
Light highlights the features that make
The game attracts the attention of local users,
Add voice translation service,
Or use an accompanying translation if you can not.
The developer console offers a mechanism for revisions
Google Play
You can then see reviews from users around the world.
Be sure to send a response to these users.
Tell them you care a lot about their opinion
And that you want to take advantage of their comments.
Users will be very happy
If you send them a response in their own language.
You can also take advantage of the experimental use of the test
Your game and game translation
Through active users in a particular country
Before launching the game on a larger scale.
Learn more about translating and implementing your app
In local markets,
You can go to the distribution section
In the Android app developer site.
And if you want to get more tips on how
Improve the performance of your app or game
Create a better business for apps,
Check out other videos in this series
Download the "Google Play App Success Secrets" guide.